[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIMON HADE: When we
started Space Ape,
things were definitely smaller.
We were only 12 people.
Now, we're 55.
TOBY MOORE: We were new
to building mobile games
but had a lot of experience
building games in general.
We just needed to
learn very quickly.
So we needed to use it as a
learning platform, as well
as making a video
game for our users.
JOE REABURN: We'd all
been kicking around
ideas of what would make
great combat strategy game.
And really, we just loved Japan.
And we loved Japanese
and Eastern fantasy.
JOHN EARNER: "Samurai Siege"
is about building and battling.
You build a fortress.
You increase its strength.
And you try and defend
it against other players
who are trying to steal
resources from you.
And you, in turn, battle them
and steal their resources.
SIMON HADE: We had
fairly modest ambitions
for "Samurai Siege" when
we kicked things off.
We launched it initially in
Australia and New Zealand.
Then, we had about a
six-week beta period.
JOHN EARNER: Within two weeks of
putting the game live on beta,
we were already making
$10,000 a day gross.
And so, we went live globally.
And within a month, we had
about 300,000 people daily.
About a 1.5 million people
playing the game monthly.
And at that point,
we really knew
that we were onto something.
These days, we make
about $55,000 a day.
It spikes on weekends.
Our biggest day,
we made $220,000,
which is both a small
number if you compare it
to some of the biggest
game companies out there,
but pretty cool if you're
18 or 24 months old,
and you're just getting
off the ground with one
of your first titles.
So we're pretty
thrilled with it.
SIMON HADE: Android part of
our revenue has been growing.
It's 50%.
A lot of the growth's coming
from our focus on Asia.
10% to 15% of our revenue, I
think, comes from Japan alone.
JOE REABURN: We always
intended to take
"Samurai Siege" to Japan.
We just wanted to make sure
that we got it right, because we
knew we had one shot at one
of the world's largest gaming
markets.
JOHN EARNER: We
spent four months
preparing Japan for launch.
And the game had been live
pretty much everywhere else.
JOE REABURN: One
of the reasons is,
we spent a long time
to localize our game
and culturalize our game, just
have a really high quality
translation.
JOHN EARNER: We learned how
users see advertisements.
We learned what they
thought about the game.
We spent a month in beta
in Japan testing it.
SIMON HADE: So we
had to find people
who would like our
game locally, who
could be ambassadors for us.
So then when we're
live, they were really
the voice of our
players in Japan.
JOE REABURN: The
alpha/beta testing feature
in the Google Play Development
Console is a good way to go.
So you can hand-select
a group of people
that are associated
with the Google group.
And then, you can start
getting feedback from users.
You start seeing how your game
performs in the real world.
For our marketing material
on the Google Play Store,
we wanted it to look like a
local Japanese company had
created it, which really
meant more exclamation
marks and cooler
character drawings.
We used our internal Japanese
staff to tell us how to look.
And we got it together.
Turns out, it looks really
cool, looks really exciting.
TOBY MOORE: Google Play
has been a great platform
to develop with.
I've really enjoyed the fast
iteration speed and the way
that Google think about bringing
games to the Google Play Store
and working with the
partnership team there.
JOHN EARNER: Experience has
been great with Google Play.
We have found that
it is about half
of our audience and
half of our business.
Thrilling as it has been to have
the success we've had to date,
the thing that we're really
looking for, that next step,
is down the road.
I think that's what keeps
people going in gaming
is it's always the thrill
of working on the next game
and seeing it go live.
And so, I'm looking
forward to the next one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]